We’d all love to become less dependent on
our phone chargers, but current wireless charging
options just aren’t there yet.
So, what if we could charge our phones..with
WIFI?!
Wireless charging devices on the market now
use something called electromagnetic induction.
First, a coiled wire in a charging pad turns
an electric current into a magnetic field.
Then that field is received by another coiled
wire in your device that turns it back into
electricity and charges the battery.
But, most of the inductive charging devices
we have today require direct or very close
contact between the device being charged and
the source of the magnetic field.
Which doesn’t do much to resolve that feeling
of being tethered to an outlet.
And while some researchers are looking for
ways to extend the distance of magnetic induction,
others are instead looking at how radiofrequency
signals (like wifi) could be used to do the
same thing.
To clarify- this isn’t new- researchers
have been working on it for a while now.
And charging via radiofrequency (or RF) signals
actually works pretty similarly to magnetic
induction.
First, a transmitter (think: your wifi router)
sends out an RF signal.
Then, a specially designed rectifying antenna
(or rectenna) in your device picks up that
signal, and converts it into an electric current.This
is a super promising technology- but there
are some drawbacks that have made developing
it challenging.
The first being charge.
Current WIFI routers don’t emit that much
power, and so would be limited to charging
low power devices like sensors or fitness
trackers.
And that would be awesome for applications
like the internet of things.
Which is, hold on on sec,I’ve got unlimited
data with Visible, so let me get a definition
for you.
Which is “the networking capability that
allows information to be sent to and received
from everyday objects and devices using the
Internet"
But, making RF charging work for things like
our phones will likely involve setting up
a new type of RF transmitter, as well as installing
rectennas in any device we want to charge.
That also presents a bit of a chicken or the
egg dilemma.
Do you install the rectennas first, or the
transmitters first?
Then there’s the issue of distance.
The farther away from the transmitter you
get, the less power you’ll be able to pick
up.
Finally, all of these systems need to get
agencies like the FCC to say they’re safe
before they can be sold to consumers.
And that can take a lot of time.
But despite all of these challenges, we’re
seeing a lot of progress.
One company called Ossia has developed an
RF receiver and transmitter duo called Cota.
The receiver in—let’s say your phone—first
sends beacon signals in various directions
around the location you're in.
The transmitter picks up these signals and
then responds by sending concentrated RF waves
along the same path—thus charging your phone.
This helps provide more energy to the device
than other systems, since you have a focused
RF signal instead of casting the power over
a large area.
Ossia also debuted a new phone case and transmitter
combination at CES this year, that allows
for continuous phone charging at up to 12
ft.
But it’s just a proof of concept.
Another promising design is from a company
called Energous.
Their technology called WattUp can charge
small devices with RF energy at a distance
of 3 ft - AND it’s already gotten FCC approval!!!!!
And they also have a newer version in the
works that claims to charge more devices at
a new distance of 15ft!
Even more, a new study from MIT has found
a way to make rectennas flexible, and do it
with cheaper materials.
Which could mean wearables powered by WiFi?
All in all, it doesn’t seem like we’re
that far off from real wireless charging at
a distance, and ditching those phone chargers
once and for all.
So what do you guys think- would you buy one?
Well what about buying a new provider?
Visible is the new way to think about phone
service.
No stores.
No annual contracts.
No hidden fees.
Just 40 bucks a month for unlimited messages,
minutes, and data at speeds up to 5 megabits
per second.
All on Verizon’s 4G LTE Network.When you
think the future of phone service, think Visible.
Don’t forget to subscribe for all your energy
science needs, and for more on the future
of wireless charging, check out this video.
One last thing- we only had time to talk about
induction and RF charging-- but some researchers
are also working on wireless charging with
infrared light.
Man, the future is gonna be awesome.
As always thanks for watching, and I’ll
see you next time on Seeker.